الرصاص المتبادل في كل
مكان. اصوات المدافع تهز
الارجاء. ازيز الطائرات يسخن
شيئا فشيئا? لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت
الحرب الداخلية في السودان?
اعمدة الدخان تغطي سماء المدن
السودانية. طائرات مجهولة تضرب
مواقع الدعم السريع. ايعقل انها
مصرية? ام انها اسرائيلية? وضع
عصيب يعيشه السودان يا سادة.
مجموعة مصرية محتجزة السوداني
ممنوع من الخروج من المنازل قتال
ضار على اشده بين اكبر قوتين
عسكريتين في السودان. ما الذي
ستؤول اليه هذه المعارك عن
الصراع العسكري السوداني نتحدث
وللقصة بقية. قصف مجهول. سجال
سياسي تحول الى طلقات رصاص
متبادلة بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع. فزع على اثرها العاصمة
على قتال ضار بين القوتين
العسكريتين الاكبر في البلاد وسط
مخاوف من توسع المواجهة بينهما.
وقد توسعت بالفعل يا اصدقاء. فهل
الى حوار من سبيل ثلاثة ايام
عصيبة عاشتها العاصمة الخرطوم
والمدن السودانية الاخرى بعد شد
وجذب ومهاترات اطراف السياسة
السودانية. لتحلق الطائرات في
الاجواء. طائرات مجهولة يقال
انها تدخلت لتساعد البرهان
والجيش السوداني. صحيفة نيويورك
تايمز تؤكد الامر بقولها ان
الطيران المصري دخل بطائراته الى
السودان وقام بقصف الدعم السريع.
المصريون لم يدلوا باي تصريحات
رسمية بخصوص الطائرات. والاعلام
المصري ينفي اي تدخل في الصراع
السوداني. لكن ما الذي يجعل
القاهرة تتدخل في الشأن
السوداني? بدأت القصة بتسريب
الدعم السريع فيديو يظهر ما فيه
احتجاز مجموعة جنود مصريين في
السودان. الجيش المصري قال بلهجة
شديدة انهم يتابعون عن كثب
الاحداث الجارية داخل الاراضي
السودانية. وفي اطار تواجد قوات
مصرية مشتركة لاجراء تدريبات مع
نظرائهم في السودان. داعيا الى
الحفاظ على امن وسلامة قواته
قائد الدعم السريع خرج فورا
ليعتذر مصرحا بان الجنود
المصريين في وسيتم اعادتهم في
الوقت المناسب. فهل يحتجزهم
كرهائن خوفا من تدخل الجيش
المصري في الصراع قبل سنوات وقعت
مصر اتفاقية دفاع مشترك مع الجيش
السوداني وليس غريبا ان تدخل
الجيش المصري اليوم في الحرب
السودانية. وبعد احتجاز مجموعة
الجنود المصرية ها هو الجيش
السوداني يطلب تدخل الجيش
المصري. تدخل سيحسم الحرب لا
محالة فنحن نتحدث اقوى جيش عربي
يا سادة. لكن ليس بعد المصريون
لن يتدخلوا حاليا بحسب تصريحاتهم
الرسمية. التعامل مع الكيان
الاسرائيلي. اصدقاء الامس اعداء
اليوم. نعم. فقائد الجيش
عبدالفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دجلو الملقب
بحميتي كان يشكلان جبهة واحدة
ومعسكرا واحدة للتخلص مما تبقى
من البشير. لكن اليوم يتصارع
الرجلان ليذهب السودان ضحية
لصراع قادته. صحيفة الصهيونية
تقول ان حميتي من الممكن انه
يتعامل مع الموساد الاسرائيلي.
الصحيفة الاسرائيلية لن تأتي
بالخبر من الهواء فلا دخان بدون
نار. ذات الصحيفة اكدت العلاقات
الجيدة التي تجمع قائد الدعم
السريع في السودان حميتي
باسرائيل لتكشف عن لقاء بمسؤولين
في جهاز الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي
الموساد. قائد الدعم السريع كان
يقود السودان الى التطبيع مع
الكيان الاسرائيلي بمعية
البرهان. حتى ان البرهان كان قد
التقى بوزير خارجية الكيان
الاسرائيلي كوهين من اجل
التطبيع. بينما قال موقع
الامريكي ان تطبيع السودان مع
اسرائيل هش وسيستغرق بعض الوقت
وسيكون مرتبطا بالتطورات في
الساحة الاسرائيلية ومناطق اخرى.
لكن واحدة منهما اي حميتي او
البرهان ومن سيذهب للتطبيع بعد
هذه الاحداث والصحف الاسرائيلية
تتحدث عن مدى قرب حميتي من
الدولة الصهيونية. فهل يستعين
بهم اليوم في صراعه على السلطة؟
وفي حال تدخل الموساد لن يقف
الجيش المصري ساكتا لكن لا نتمنى
ان تؤول الامور الى ذلك فالشعب
السوداني سيكون الضحية. احتدام
المعارك. تواصل القتال لليوم
الثالث بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم ومناطق
اخرى. تواترت الدعوات الدولية
لوقف اطلاق النار تجددت
الاشتباكات في نقاط عدة بالخرطوم
وتضاربت الروايات بين الجانبين.
كل يطلق تصريحاته بحسم المعركة
قريبا ولا شيء مؤكد على الارض.
التعتيم الاعلامي هو سيد الموقف
الغموض بشأن نطاق السيطرة
الميدانية لكلا الطرفين. التجول
محظور. وسائل الاعلام قابعة في
مخابئها. الجيش السوداني يأمر
المواطنين بعدم الخروج من
المنازل يا لها من اوضاع خانقة.
وفي حين تدور المعارك العنيفة في
انحاء البلاد تحدث الدعم السريع
عن سيطرة قواته على مواقع
استراتيجية في العاصمة بينها مقر
القيادة العامة للقوات المسلحة
والقصر الجمهوري ومقر الاذاعة
والتليفزيون في ام درمان. نفى
الجيش صحة ذلك واكد انه متمسك
بكل مقاره وانه يقترب كثيرا من
لحظة الحسم مشيرا الى انه
سيستقدم تعزيزات للخرطوم. ومعارك
كر وفر في مدينة مروي التي تضم
قاعدة عسكرية ومطار مدني. وفي
غضون ذلك تبادل قائد الجيش
عبدالفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم محمد حمدان دجلو حميتي
الاتهامات والتهديدات واكد كل
منهما انه سيلاحق الاخر كما ان
حميتي دعا المجتمع الدولي للتدخل
متهما خصمه البرهان باستهداف
المدنيين بواسطة الطيران الحربي.
دول عديدة عربية وعالمي. طالبت
بخفض التصعيد حذرت الامم المتحدة
من ان كل تصعيد اضافي في السودان
ستكون له تداعيات لكن ويا للاسف
ليس هناك مؤشرات على استعداد
الاطراف المتقاتلة لابرام هدنة
بحسب المبعوث الاممي الى السودان
مائة وثمانون قتيلا الف
وثمانمائة جريح حصيلة المعارك
المستعيرة على الارض منذ ثلاثة
ايام وهي ارقام لا تدل على عدد
الضحايا الحقيقي فهذا فقط ما يصل
الى المستشفيات من المدنيين.
فماذا عن من لم يصل للمستشفيات?
وماذا عن الضحايا من جنود
الطرفين? لا احد يعلم حتى الان.
هكذا هي الحروب يا سادة. فما
بالنا بحرب الية بين ابناء بلد
واحد. ليعلنها مارتن جريفث وكيل
الامين العام للامم المتحدة
للشؤون الانسانية ان ستة عشر
مليون شخص هم ثلث سكان السودان
بحاجة الى مساعدات انسانية. وفي
اليوم الثالث للحرب ها هو
التليفزيون الرسمي السوداني
يستأنف البث بعد انقطاعه لساعات
وبعد ان كان الدعم السريع قد
اعلن سيطرته عليه ليبث
التليفزيون اغنيات وطنية سودانية
واشادات باداء الجيش. السودان
يغوص في الرمل والاحداث مؤسفة
جدا. حتى ان هذا الذي يحدث في
السودان سيؤثر على قرار مصر
بخصوص سد النهضة. خصوصا على
مستوى التنسيق العسكري بين مصر
والسودان باتجاه وسيؤثر على
السودان بشكل كارثي. فامن
السودان ومصر المائي في خطر
شديد. وبينما تستطيع مصر الرد
عسكريا للحفاظ على حقها في نهر
النيل يذهب السودان في اتون حرب
اهلية. فهل يصل السودان بذلك الى
مرحلة مأساوية اكثر مما هو فيه
بسبب سد النهضة ايضا?